al final la frontera esa simple barrera
en el último puesto de control entre
camerún y la pública centroafricana es
un punto fronterizo oficialmente cerrado
y custodiado por el ejército camerunés
esto no impide el paso de los refugiados
centroafricanos que huyen de los
combates de los últimos días la mayoría
de ellos se incorporan a campamentos ya
abarrotados como esta el campamento de
gado a unos 30 km de la zona fronteriza
las asignaciones de vivienda tiene en
cuenta el tamaño de la familia está
mañana mismo ser hábil y sus equipos
están movilizados estos agentes del alto
comisionado de las naciones unidas para
los refugiados acaban de levantar 300
nuevos refugios de emergencia en el
campamento bastan para acoger a los
miles de centroafricanos que siguen
llegando con la reanudación de los
combates desde las disputadas elecciones
presidenciales desde los últimos
acontecimientos en la república
centroafricana hemos registrado a más de
5.000 personas
kraft lu cosas no estamos aunando
esfuerzos para poder aliviar el
sufrimiento de estas poblaciones de por
sí vulnerables
en las últimas llegadas se encuentra a
vanessa una joven discapacitada que pudo
huir de la república centroafricana con
sus dos hijas pequeñas forman parte de
un grupo de 270 refugiados que han
escapado de las aldeas del noroeste del
país en los alrededores de bower estas
localidades son regularmente objeto de
ataques por parte de los grupos rebeldes
si mi hermana no hubiera venido a
woodward a buscarme en mis hijos y yo
habríamos sido
fusilados por los rebeldes aquí tengo la
sensación de encontrar paz y
tranquilidad no puedo caminar pero desde
que estuve aquí he recibido comida de
ayuda de la comunidad no estoy segura de
querer volver a mi país
a pocos kilómetros se encuentra en la
tierra de nadie de esta larguísima
frontera camerunesa centroafricana
vigilada de cerca por las fuerzas
especiales cameruneses no sky entra en
el dispositivo
la inspección comienza con las
estaciones golf un el golf 2 y golf 3
bajo las órdenes del coronel en vez
los militares cameruneses intentan
evitar que conflictos en trafica no se
extiende al territorio camerunés quieren
evitar una incursión rebelde desde la
república centroafricana que podría
desestabilizar a camerún en los últimos
meses ya se han producido intrusiones
protagonizadas por los grupos armados
que controlan el largo centro africano
de la frontera ahora cuál es el estado
de su puesto por el momento estos
rebeldes pretenden asfixiar a bungee
organizando un bloqueo de la capital
centroafricana desde la frontera
camerunés a los rebeldes se han fijado
los objetivos vencer las defensas de
banguí y controlar la principal
carretera de abastecimiento es decir el
gran corredor que va a dejar o abul hay
avance y la presión de los rebeldes nos
hizo implementar este dispositivo con
firmeza así pudimos detener el avance de
los rebeldes
este corredor gal desde camerún es una
ruta de abastecimiento crucial para la
república centroafricana un país sin
salida al mar pero al multiplicar los
ataques en esta ruta transfronteriza los
rebeldes ya han provocado la
paralización de gran parte del comercio
el resultado cientos de camiones
bloqueados no pudieron continuar su
viaje a bani debido a la inseguridad así
que están esperando aquí para un
hipotético cruce de frontera
ni siquiera comemos bien miren como
preparamos aquí desde hace un mes más de
800 transportadores sobreviven en éste
para agotando cada día sus escasas
raciones de alimentos son conductores
con envíos de alimentos perecederos
pudriéndose en sus camiones entre ellos
este joven conductor centroafricano muy
preocupa desde la reanudación de los
combates uma no tiene noticias de su
familia en la republica se trafica somos
transportadores ni siquiera estamos en
política es lo que sucede en nuestro
camino tampoco lo sabemos no tenemos
ninguna información de nuestras familias
y mucho menos sabemos cómo están allá no
hemos venido a quedarnos aquí estamos
atascados estamos desamparados incluso
ese día hay un pequeño rayo de esperanza
el puesto fronterizo se reabrió
momentáneamente
una treintena de camiones escoltados por
los cascos azules consiguieron
finalmente salir de la república
centroafricana pasamos un mes en la
república centroafricana bien como ya
estamos en el país es bueno a pesar de
esta breve apertura del corredor
comercial el cierre del puesto
fronterizo es una catástrofe económica
para garúa uruguay la principal ciudad
fronteriza de cameron aquí los
centroafricanos representan generalmente
el 98 por ciento de la clientela para
los comerciantes de este mercado las
consecuencias financieras son graves
tenemos que cambiar eso con otra peluca
en la bolsa
samsung team and tiene cada vez más
dificultades para vender sus accesorios
de moda femenina calcula que ya ha
perdido dos meses de ingresos desde que
se reanudaron los combates en la
república centroafricana a finales de
diciembre miren ya son las nueve no hay
nadie en el mercado yo así desde el 18
de diciembre todavía que al stoke de
diciembre que está atascado ahí se dan
un paseo por la ciudad superan que todo
está muerto la ciudad de carga bola y
vive gracias a los centroafricanos y
cuando se bloquea allí apenas trabajamos
aquí en realidad es muy complicado
se complique
pero abu la ciudad mas centroafricana de
camerún vive con el temor de una
conflagración general al otro lado de la
frontera una nueva crisis en la
república centroafricana que según el
alto comisionado para los refugiados ha
empujado a más de 60.000 civiles a
buscar refugio en los países vecinos de
vuelta a los caminos del exilio como en
una pesadilla interminable